foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
the importance of timing managing
covid-19 with a live q a this webinar is
part of the 2022 microbiology virtual
week and I'm Susie Valdez of labroots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational seminar is
presented by labroots so let's get
started before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to First
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find that live chat located at the right
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation so to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click Send now if you you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just simply click on the
help desk button located at the bottom
of your screen within the navigation bar
or from the lobby and finally as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on that
continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits I now
present today's speaker Dr Daniel
Griffin
Dr Griffin is the chief of the division
of infectious disease at Optum Tri-State
and the clinical instructor of medicine
at Columbia University College of
Physicians and surgeons in the
Department of Medicine in the division
of infectious diseases Dr Griffin
welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
all right thank you so much and welcome
everybody
um you know I just want to reinforce
that I'm going to be talking for a bit
too long perhaps but the biggest thing I
want people to be doing is thinking of
those questions I'm going to be focused
on the importance of timing in managing
of covid 19. we have three main learning
objectives
um one I would like people to walk away
from this one hour of their life
understanding the viral kinetics and the
impact on testing for patients with
covid-19 this has evolved over time so
we're going to be talking quite a bit
about that that's going to lead directly
into what are our available testing
options I'm hoping people are going to
really have a good solid understanding
of the available testing options if we
can't make the diagnosis how do we move
on to number three which is I want
everyone to be able to apply to what
right time recognize the right time for
the right therapeutic in an individual
patient and this has evolved over time
we've come to really understand that the
right drug at the wrong time ceases to
be the right drug so we'll be spending
some time on that so right into the
abstract and this is going to be the
most verbiage you see on the screen for
the next hour so critical in control of
this pandemic is the ability to rapidly
identify infectious individuals prior to
their ability to infect others right if
we can do something as we're heading
into this fall and this winter to keep
folks from spreading it to others that
definitely is challenging with the
introduction of better testing capacity
and an understanding of how to use these
tests the current challenge is making
sure patients have access to the correct
therapies at the right time a simplified
framework so there has been a framework
but now we have a simplified framework
for identity identifying the phases for
different therapies and every
application of available Therapeutics
can greatly improve the chances of a
positive outcome so what what are these
stages now
there are two pre-clinical periods we'll
be talking about what what we can do in
the pre-exposure period this is before
you've been exposed to someone we're
going to be talking about you've been
exposed and potentially now you're
incubating the the virus is starting to
replicate but not at the point where you
test positive not at the point we have
symptoms and then we'll move into the
four clinical phases
the early viral upper restory
non-hypoxic phase this is maybe referred
to as the mild covet
not necessarily meaning it's going to
remain mild then we have the next phase
we'll be talking about the early
inflammatory lower respiratory hypoxic
phase right this is that week two this
is uh what caused our hospitals to get
flooded with patients requiring
respiratory support that's where we're
seeing a lot of patients really heading
in the wrong direction but when we're
going to talk also about the fact that
this is not a one-week illness it's not
a two-week illness for a lot of
individuals there is a secondary
symptomatic phase we'll talk about is
this the rebound that people are talking
about is this a second rebound we're
also going to spend a little time on the
tail phase what do we know about it what
can we do about it
um and everything I'm going to be
talking about is evidence-based
um it's in line with the following
guidelines the guidelines of the ID
Society of America the NIH covid
treatment guidelines and what I do want
to point out is that there's a certain
urgency uh you know the amount of
enthusiasm you'll hear in the next hour
is not just because I had a cup of
coffee with an espresso shot but the
fact that here we are in September of
2022 we are still seeing about 500
deaths a day in the United States from
covid 19. and I am going to put forward
that the majority of those deaths are
preventable and if we really know the
science if we know the evidence if we
can have those conversations with our
patients we ourselves might eventually
be patient so if we can also know from
that end what to do I would like to see
that number really go down so let's go
through so we'll start with the
pre-exposure period right we we've been
talking about masks now for two years uh
ideally we would have been talking about
mass for a little bit longer than two
years
but we have moved from everyone wearing
masks to widespread Mass mandates to
more vulnerable individuals using what
we refer to as one-way masking so the
the risk of a bad outcome with covid is
very different for very different
individuals the young healthy individual
is at relatively low risk of ending up
in the hospital
relatively low risk of death there still
is the long coveted risk but for elderly
individuals majority of deaths are now
occurring in people over the age of 80.
these individuals are now going into
circumstances where they want to keep
themselves safe and so we'll be talking
a little bit about what those what those
different mask options are physical
distancing
um this continues to be something that
we need to talk to our patients about
we've really understood that this is a
respiratory disease so as a respiratory
disease there is a benefit there is a
risk reduction to getting three feet
away getting six feet away but that
really has the biggest impact when we
are Outdoors Outdoors is safer versus
indoors there's certainly a degree of
spread that occurs because of poor
ventilation a lot of spread occurs in
that Suburban home in that poorly
ventilated office so Outdoors is
certainly safer than indoors again
something to think about in our higher
risk individuals who are being invited
to these large Gatherings moving us into
limiting the size of gatherings is still
is critical
um
small group together is quite a bit
different than a large group the more
people there the more chance that you're
going to introduce a person into that
crowd who is infectious to others
particularly if that's indoors we can
really see significant secondary spread
now washing hands and hygiene I like to
say can help I want people to stop
washing their hands but this is really
not a contact transmitted pathogen this
is really a respiratory transmission
frequent testing right this is going to
have to be judged there's that young
low-risk person have to get tested you
know three times a week like some of our
businesses were doing should testing be
done when a person is going to
potentially be around someone who's high
risk so frequent testing but really I
like to say intelligent use of those
tests we have a lot of access to tests
but let's use them intelligently
symptom checking this helps a little but
as we've run into maybe less so now
individuals can be infectious to others
before the onset of symptoms even people
can remain asymptomatic during their
entire infection and still spread it to
others so something symptom checking
helps a little but this is not like
influenza this is not like some of our
other infectious agents and vaccines
we're going to be spending a bunch of
time on vaccines I'm hoping there's
going to be a bunch of questions on
these bivalent boosters that just got
approved that people are now scheduling
where do they fit in what are we hoping
to accomplish and I am going to really
Hammer the distinction that vaccines
prevent severe disease they do not
prevent all infections and hopefully
that's really clear to everyone now but
we'll talk about what that means all
right so masks
um this is as I mentioned we have moved
into the one-way masking period
there are different types of masks um
and these different masks have different
abilities to protect us and they also
have different abilities to protect
individuals in large Gatherings really
the the respirators the n95s the kn95s
these are really those masks that we're
recommending for those highest risk
individuals who want to get out there
they want to go to that big indoor event
because it's important to them maybe
it's a graduation maybe it's a birthday
party maybe it's some celebration maybe
it's upcoming holidays and this is where
we have that conversation to provide
them with the most personal protection
the highest level of personal protection
the quality of masks I mean it may not
match your your evening gown it may not
match your bow tie I have a lot of
wonderful cloth masks but for that
highest level of protection the type of
mask does matter
pre-exposure in most situations now the
MRNA vaccines are preferred we have the
Pfizer Bion Tech we have the moderna
vaccines these are preferred over J and
J
um you know for completeness I should
throw in the mix that we now have
novovax we now have the protein subunit
vaccine now what what is the goal of our
vaccines and what are we seeing and what
sort of discussion do we have to have
with our patients I think the biggest
thing here is we do not want false
expectations you know now that we're
hearing about polio again that's a
that's a good disease to use as an
example the injectable polio vaccine
protection against infection zero the
protection against infection that we get
with our vaccines I like it to sunblock
okay even if we say a 90 protection if
you put 90 percent protection on your
skin and then you spend the entire day
laying out at the equator you're still
going to get a sunburn so these vaccines
are going to reduce our risks of
infection probably temporary probably
during that period of time when those
antibodies are very high but as the
antibodies go down individuals are
increasing risk of getting infected but
what we've seen with a significant
degree of durability is protection
against death protection against ending
up in the hospital protection against
ending on a ventilator there's a hope
now that with our updated bivalent
boosters which are now available that
for some appropriate period of time
based on timing we're going to get some
added protection maybe some decrease in
infection we're certainly going to get a
boost in those antibodies and
individuals but again you don't want a
patient to feel like the vaccine has
failed when they get infected because
people certainly get infected after the
vaccine but as I always you know ask my
patients but did you die did you end up
on a van later did we keep you out of
the hospital so really important that we
encourage vaccination who's dying and it
still shocks me the majority of patients
that ended up in the hospital are still
the unvaccinated even though they make
up a minority of our high risk
individuals
but what about those individuals who
have been vaccinated but for some reason
are still at at risk of a bad outcome
either they're immunocompromised or they
for some reason are not able to tolerate
the vaccine or for some reason cannot
get a response to the vaccine so instead
of hoping that they make those
antibodies which in some cases they
can't this is really an under utilized
therapeutic and this is the passive
immunization this is Abu shelled which I
tell people let's not turn this into Ebu
shelf and this is really impressive this
is actually data that we have which is
really compelling and it's actually
protection even against infection a
greater than 90 percent reduction in
developing symptomatic covid-19 so this
graph I sort of show and you can see
this incredible separation this is now
something still paid for by the
government it is now recommended every
six months we are seeing a 95 percent
reduction in people even developing
symptomatic covet and remember we are
giving this to high-risk individuals
immunocompromised unable to develop
their own antibody responses and in
addition to the prevention of
symptomaticovid we're seeing reduction
in the risk of progression
hospitalization significant mortality
benefits so let's think about those 500
people dying a day a number of them are
unvaccinated we need to address that
those that are vaccinated tend to be
older you know compromised multiple
medical problems another big reduction
if we start employing Ebu shelled in our
high risk qualifying patients and we're
going to be talking about even more
things we can do so remember this is
pre-exposure you want to get in here
before a person has been infected before
they're in that incubation period
because unfortunately now we move into
the incubation period and this has
unfortunately changed over over time
currently a person is exposed they may
be in the process of moving forward to
being infected maybe moving forward to
having a symptomatic case of covid-19
currently we have no evidence-based
Therapeutics in this space we used to be
doing post-exposure monoclonal
antibodies we used to be using uh
regeneron the regeneron cocktail the Eli
Lily cocktail
those have been pulled off because we
currently do not think they have
efficacy against the currently
circulating variants
unfortunately even after they were
pulled off even after they were
deauthorized even after we said they no
longer worked about 150 000 doses were
still given out but no let's follow the
science unfortunately right now this is
an open space what about jumping in with
PEX lovit or something that we'll jump
in with we'll talk about later in this
space that has not shown to be benefit
So currently in this incubation period
this is someone you're watching someone
you're waiting seeing do they actually
end up developing covid-19 and we'll
move into what happens next
so we've now talked about the
pre-exposure period we've talked about
this incubation period and there is a
range here we say 2 to 14 days it's
still 2 to 14 days but with current
variance there's been a shift to the
left here starting with the ancestral
strain median about seven days and then
we've moved down now to a median of only
about four days from time of exposure
until people test positive but that's
your median there's a left shift but
there continues to be a tail where
individuals are exposed but they do not
test positive until out to about day 14.
once you get past day 10 you're starting
to get only down to a few percent that
still will end up with a positive test
after that so again we're seeing a front
load in that incubation period but now
we're going to move into what really is
going to be critical is has our patient
moved into the early viral upper rest
rate non-hypoxic phase this is the viral
replication phase this is the period of
viral symptoms
this is really the time when we have the
ability to make the biggest difference
um as we'll see once we get into the
second week diminishing return so we've
already already talked about a 90
reduction in progression to
hospitalization and death with our
vaccines we've talked about adding Abu
shells to our immunocompromised to some
of our more vulnerable folks but what do
we do at this point well the biggest
thing we need to do is we need to make
the diagnosis and the way we're going to
be making that diagnosis is using our
tests so we still have our nucleic acid
amplification test those those pcrs and
all the PCR equivalents those isothermal
point-of-care machines
this continues to be a very sensitive
and specific way of making the diagnosis
but what we've really seen and I think
this is positive is an expansion of
acceptance and accessibility of our
antigen tests I'm I'm going to go ahead
and I'm going to suggest that these are
just as sensitive and accurate for
Omicron as they were for Delta and the
other variants but again timing is going
to matter when you do these tests so a
big change that we have seen over time
is we are starting to see symptoms
preceding the positive tests and we're
introducing the role of repeat testing
orthogonal testing as we the fancy word
for that some suggested this is because
of Prior infection because of
vaccination it's not clear that a person
who is unvaccinated and having their
first infection with the current
variance does not follow the same
pattern that the vaccinated in previous
so this looks like this is actually a
feature of the current variance is that
people often have symptoms before they
get that positive test so this is the
current recommendation person starts to
have those symptoms that first day if
there's a reasonable reason to be
concerned There is almost all the time
they wait that first day the second day
is when you're going to start testing
the individual if they have so we'll say
date Zero is the onset of symptoms we'll
make that a Sunday Monday morning is
when you want to do that test first time
in the morning is a great way to do it
if it's positive then you can feel
pretty confident if it is negative on
day one on Monday then it is recommended
that you actually repeat tests you might
repeat that test Tuesday or the
recommendation is Wednesday morning 48
hours apart before you feel confident
that this is something else one of the
important things is there there can be
something else people can have more than
one infection people can have something
other than covid I think we've come to
realize that co-infections are a
significant part of infections across
the board we realize that a lot of
individuals with covid may also have the
flu they may also have an enter or
rhinovirus and then the reverse of that
might be true as well just because you
have influenza does it mean you don't
also have covet so the the flu Rona
thing that is circulated but really just
making us appreciate you can't rule out
covid with a positive flu test the way
you rule out covid is with a negative
covet test and if a person is Coveted
and the flu you may even be considering
treating both
um but I will say these are really
um viral co-infections so we're going to
be talking a little bit about how often
do people actually have
bacterial co-infections how often should
we be giving out the antibiotics and as
we're going to talk about a little bit
that's going to become not so often
so really important first off remember
our Oaths Do no harm this first week you
want to avoid steroids let me talk a
little bit about the data here but
giving someone with covid steroids
during that first week is going to
increase their progression to
hospitalization or death about
three-fold maybe even more so you really
want to not give these people steroids
at the wrong time so where are we in the
disease process it's the first week we
want to avoid steroids we'll go into the
data on that we also want to avoid
unnecessary antibiotics things like
azithromycin doxycycline big
meta-analysis big studies only about
three to four percent of people with
covid-19 end up with a bacterial
infection during their entire course so
if we're giving out antibiotics more
than about three or four percent of the
time we're not doing anything helpful
we're messing with the microbiome and
someone who's already trying to fight
off covid we're increasing animal
microbial resistant rates we're giving
drugs that might actually potentially
have cardiac impacts to individuals with
a disease with cardiac impacts and the
biggest thing we also have to start
doing is or stop doing is let's stop
recommending or prescribing unproven
remedies don't just grab stuff off the
shelf don't grab that zinc because all
it's going to do is make your patients
vomit and give them GI upset don't give
them the Ivermectin or the fluvoxamine
we've looked at that not helpful and
there actually are lost opportunity
costs so let's follow the science here
but let's talk a little bit about when I
say Do no harm why do I get so fired up
about the steroids so
number of studies we looked at timing
given in that first week to patients who
are not hypoxic who just are in that
early viral replication early viral
symptom phased on hypoxic phase overall
progression to severe disease and
hospitalization increased six-fold in
one study in that same study we saw a
mortality increase by 35 percent if
given in the first week
we also saw in another study that given
steroids was associated with a hospital
admission adjusted odds ratio of 2.5 so
2.5 times as likely to end up in the
hospital in this study giving them
steroids when they didn't need them
doubling of cardiac events almost a
tripling of their risk of ending up with
a pulmonary embolism and in this study
greater than a 3.4 adjusted odds ratio
of dying if we give steroids in that
first week steroids in the first week is
bad bad news for folks with covet let's
not do this I know some people think oh
well the cough is really bad it will
make them feel better it'll make them
feel better for a week but it may end up
pushing them in the wrong direction they
may end up in the hospital they may end
up dying that will be potentially our
fault so let's not do that what else do
we not want to do as I mentioned we do
not want to give antibiotics when they
are unnecessary there are a few three to
four percent of the time when there's an
Associated bacterial infection if you're
giving antibiotics more often than that
you're overdoing it there are multiple
studies showing no benefit and potential
harms doxycycline study actually twice
as many people died in the doxycycline
group as the group that did not get
doxycycline not statistically
significant but boy doubling someone's
chance of death not great azithromycin
multiple studies no meaningful benefit
over 80 percent in some studies 90 of
folks with covid-19 have ended up
getting antibiotics so we really need to
rein that in that is not helpful but
what is
so we'll go to the recommended
evidence-based therapies I'm going to go
through these one at a time
um but this is the order as far as
recommended and we're going to go
through what we can do so pack slope
it's going to be number one REM death
severe early IB remdessavir number two
poorly operationalized but evidence
there that we'll discuss monoclonal
antibodies we still have beptalovumab we
still have one and we'll talk about that
and number four it's really three and
four because monoclonal antibodies and
malnut peer review are sort of grouped
together
that's also going to be a potential way
of preventing people from progressing to
hospitalization and death and we'll talk
about the data but first what I think a
lot of people have been talking a lot
about is PAX lovit so hopefully people
are preparing those questions about
paxlove at rebound is it better to give
this is it better not is five days
enough we'll talk about the signs there
but let's start with what we know about
pacslovit so Pax lovid if given in the
first three to five days is going to
give us almost a 90 reduction in
progression to hospitalization and death
so let's start adding up let's start off
with those individuals who are
unvaccinated this where this data
applies but what about those individuals
who are vaccinated we now have data
showing that these individuals get a
benefit as well it may not be 90 it may
be about 75 percent but still ninety
percent reduction with the vaccination
another 70 80 percent reduction with
early treatment in that first week not
making things worse with steroids not
making things worse with antibiotics
um so Pax lovid is currently
authorized eua to be given to
individuals in this first week it is the
number one recommended
um there there can be a a little bit of
a lift this actually takes a little bit
of time
um you don't just check the box
um one of the things you want to do is
you want to know is my patient at risk
if you're looking at a healthy 30 year
old with no medical problems and their
risk of going to the hospital is
hospital is zero their risk of going to
the hospital will remain at zero packs a
little bit is not going to provide
benefit remember the science here is
that Pax lobe it prevents progression to
hospital prevents progression to death
we do not know if it prevents long covid
we do not think that it makes symptoms
better significantly quicker it's
actually hard to tell from placebo group
if there's a significant impact on
symptoms everyone thinks there is I'll
tell you that there's definitely a
psychological perception that this makes
you feel better quicker but number one
you want to look at the list of factors
for progression to severe illness and
you probably want to do this with your
patients encouraging patients to go and
meet with their Primary Care Providers
do this ahead of time have a plan in
place do you qualify for early
intervention in that first week if you
do what is the basis for that the next
you want to find out where is the
product we're getting a lot better at
this point it's almost in all the
pharmacies so that's not quite as as
heavy a lift the next drug interactions
and we have some tools to help with that
if they're on the Statin you're going to
be stopping that for a period of time
some other drugs you're going to
actually have to be making decisions
about there certainly are a number of
drug interactions and are patients who
are higher risk with multiple medical
problems these are going to be the
patients who have those multiple drugs
and you're going to be looking at those
interactions and sometimes you're not
going to feel comfortable with doing the
Pax lovid and we'll move on to our other
options
the next thing and I think I'll mention
is renal function you need to know their
kidney function you don't necessarily
have to know it the moment you prescribe
the medicine but if you prescribe that
medicine you can go ahead and check
kidney function and then if you need to
and I'm going to kind of throw these
numbers out if kidney function is normal
they get a normal script if the kidney
function is below 60 GFR below 60 then
you're going to actually drop down to a
renal dose if they have renal failure
less than 30 then you're going to want
to look at alternative therapies so
you're going to need to know are they at
risk because those are the people that
benefit you're going to want to know
where can I get the product you're going
to want to know what their medicines are
and you're going to want to know their
kidney function but remember this is
significant we have 500 people dying a
day we can drop that by another 80
percent by jumping in here 80 90
depending if we're talking about an
unvaccinated or vaccinated individual so
this does benefit people with um
with vaccination but what about rebound
unfortunately we've heard a lot about
the covid-19 rebound and this is defined
in many ways sometimes it's folks who
had a positive test got a negative test
now the antigen test is positive again
does that bother me would that stop me
from reducing a person's risk of ending
up in hospital or Dying by 80 to 90
percent no I would move forward with
this some people and we'll talk about
this have a viral symptom phase they
feel better and now they move into week
two where they have that hypoxic early
pulmonary phase
that does not stop me from giving them
Pax lovid because even if they have that
we have an 80 to 90 percent reduction of
them ending up in the hospital during
that second week so paxilova has gotten
a lot of press the FDA has asked um
Pfizer to study five versus ten days
we're waiting for the science on that
um five days is what's recommended five
days is what the science shows remember
think about what we're trying to do
we're trying to shut down the viral
replication that really is an issue
during that first week it's that first
week the viral replication triggers that
cytokine storm during that second week
so my advisor or the science I would say
is let's not deprive our patients of a
truly effective therapy just because of
what's going on in the media look
closely at the science now as I
mentioned here Ram de severe is number
two now this change the order changed
here a while back but this is poorly
operationalized so unfortunately when we
have that patient for whom we don't want
to do the Pax lovid maybe it's an issue
with a drug drug interaction maybe it's
an issue with the renal function being
too low ideally The Next Step would be
to offer them remda severe and what what
is the science here now
severe is certainly a drug that was
plagued with being used at the wrong
time if you use an antiviral after the
viral replication is already on the way
down
hopefully you wouldn't expect much
benefit there and we did not see that
but REM desevere if given in the first
five to seven days in the first week a
three day 200 milligrams and then 100
100 is associated with an 87 reduction
in progression to hospitalization severe
disease and death so really a huge
benefit here if given unfortunately as
we look out a lot of Health Care Systems
have not really operationalized this
because it is IV you've got to go
somewhere you've got to go somewhere for
three days but 87 reduction so it really
really impressive
intervention if our patients have access
all right so monoclonal antibodies and
talk a little bit about this because
monoclonals multiple are sort of grouped
together why are the monoclonals not way
above malnut peer review
um well let's let's talk about that
um and part of it is a changing
landscape early on I will suggest that
the regeneron cocktail the Eli Lily
cocktail really had a major impact upon
the number of people that were
progressing the hospitalization severe
disease we were looking at numbers in
the mid 80s not quite paxilovid level we
probably were seeing a period of time
after that infusion where there were
continued to be protected against those
early circulating variants data was
really compelling and then onto the
scene came Omicron unfortunately with
the Omicron variants with some of the
changes in those even though we thought
maybe certain of our monoclonal
antibodies would be variant proof
variant resisted we really lost efficacy
of those agents and it dropped us down
to the one last standing acute therapy
monoclonal which is beb talova map now
we do not have any
efficacy data on beptolova map we are
hoping it works we suspect it works we
have data from the lab showing that it
should neutralize the current
circulating variants but without
efficacy data it's a bit of a challenge
one of the other challenges is that
beptalovumab is moving from being
purchased by the government to now being
purchased commercially that is really
bumped up the the price tag now patients
are expected to cover this some of our
local Health Care Systems twelve
thousand dollars if you show up and get
your beb telova map so something for us
to be thinking about if we're moving
down this far into the list we're not
sure about the efficacy and also we're
moving from therapies that you can start
right away and I think that's another
issue timing really matters a lot of
Healthcare centers say that's great
we'll take your name we'll take your
number fortunately you're calling us on
a Friday so we'll try to get to you
Monday or Tuesday of next week every day
that we delay monoclonals and we have
data from the early monoclonals we are
losing efficacy so that's why maldu
piravir has moved right up to be on par
to be thinking about with monoclonal
antibodies so malnut peer reviewer
Thor's hammer let's talk a little bit
about this early data we were very
excited but by the time those initial
studies that stood behind the eua were
published we were only seeing about a 30
percent reduction in progression there's
certain benefits to malenu peer reviewer
no renal issues no drug drug
interactions it's on the shelves so it's
something your patient can get on right
away so we're not going to have that
delay I'll also say that we do now have
data real world data in the unvaccinated
real world data in the vaccinated
showing reduction of progression to
hospitalization or death actually even a
little bit more impressive than the
early eua suggested
um but you want to be a little bit
careful here women of childbearing age
we want to get that negative pregnancy
test we don't want them to get pregnant
while they're on this therapy it's also
not authorized for those under the age
of 18. so we're going to have a little
bit of a impact here as far as who can
who can use this but I feel like this is
an underutilized medicine
all right
so we're we're not quite to the the
pulmonary phase which we're going to
spend a little time on but that person
comes in during that first week a big
thing that they keep asking us now is
after five days am I fine can I go back
out can I do these things and so the CDC
guidance what is the science and I want
to sort of be focused here on the
subtleties this is not just a five-day
disease the height of transmission the
most infections are transmitted two days
before five days after but that doesn't
Define a hundred percent so there are
rules there are advice there's guidance
some people follow them many people
don't
after those first five days a lot of
folks need to get back to work they need
to get back to doing these other things
the CDC is saying you still may be
infectious after day five and the
recommendation and we can have this
conversation with our patients is they
should continue to wear a well-fitting
mask around others at home and in the
public for an additional five days one
of the changes here is a lot of
discussion about can I just do that
rapid antigen test can I get out of
isolation sooner maybe I need to stay in
isolation longer and so the CDC has
actually introduced testing
to isolation so as they say if an
individual has access to a test and
wants to test the best approach is to
use an antigen test toward the end of
the five-day isolation period really
interesting if you look through kind of
the details here you need to be fever
free for 24 hours without something
keeping you fever free
but but how well does this work what's
the predictive value and so just I'm
going to touch a little bit on this
maybe there'll be some questions here
what if we go ahead and look at those
tests here it is it's day six or seven
you get that negative antigen test
you're feeling pretty good 50 of those
folks with a negative antigen test
actually have a positive viral culture
you can flip it around and look at the
other way well what if you have a
positive test on day seven or so well
about fifty percent of those people
don't have a positive viral culture so
I'm going to again suggest that timing
is the
most predictive in even cases of ending
isolation the first five days you're the
most contagious and that drops and drops
and drops in the early studies out of
Taiwan we saw no transmission after day
seven zero and this is looking at
thousands of individuals there has been
some shift we think with the current
circulating variance that the period of
transmission of infectious this may not
be the same as the early ones
but I want to throw this out there
because there's a lot of excitement
about testing but there's still a lot of
uncertainty
and now and I think this is really
critical the early inflammatory lower
respiratory hypoxic phase that's week
two folks get through week one
particularly high risk people and this
is when I say all right I'm not as
worried about week one we do certainly
see people during week when end up in
the hospital they feel crummy they've
got diarrhea they're vomiting they can't
keep up with po intake they're frail and
this pushed them over the line but it's
weak two which is really what drove a
lot of the hospitalizations this is the
cytokine storm this is when they start
dropping their blood oxygen levels this
is when I want my patients monitoring
their oxygen this is where if I
vaccinated them and given them early
treatment I've significantly reduced the
risk that this is going to get severe
enough that they'll require in the
hospital but remember this is week two
this is the second week when some people
started to feel better and now they feel
worse we've been seeing that for two
years I joke with my patients who didn't
get paxilovid when they have symptoms
during week two I said oh that's packed
slow but rebound they say but Dr Griffin
I never took paxila but it doesn't
matter we're all calling it packs logo
to rebound and if we don't I'm not going
to get that media spot on CNN so the
important thing to think about during
week two is what can we do and I want to
point out we're now at a time of
diminishing returns we're not talking
about 90 reduction in progressing we're
talking about more modest benefits and
and what are those modest benefits
accomplished by doing now is when you
can start thinking about steroids
remember first week you are doing harm
with steroids you are increasing their
risk of a bad outcome but during this
second week when they start to get
hypoxic when they drop down below 94 who
might be 93 92 or 90. this is when
steroids may have a mortality benefit
maybe a 30 35 reduction as opposed to a
full increased used at the wrong time
we may be able to accomplish more
immunomobulation with our il-6 receptor
Inhibitors things like toasty this is
also when we want to start talk talking
about anticoagulation we have different
recommendations based upon whether
they're in the ICU whether they're on
the floor but all our recommendations
have the caveat of look at your
individual patient is this a 300 pound
person laying there in bed not moving
around or is this your 52 year old
person pacing back and forth as they
finish off that remdess of air so
anticoagulation across the board but we
want to adjust dose based on risk
factors based upon severity of disease
current recommendation floor patients
the default is full dose ICU is low dose
because of the increased the
prophylactic dose because of increased
bleeding a lot of guidance on pulmonary
support this has come a long way we're
trying to keep folks off those
ventilators we're trying to use high
flow nasal cannul a non-invasive
ventilatory techniques and we still have
some benefit if given within the first
10 days of antiviral therapy with REM
death severe but remember diminishing
returns most of our benefit is if we can
jump in early
secondary symptom phase and I think this
is important some people have that I
felt worse during the first week I felt
worse again during the second week but
some folks will do fine for a while and
then about week three or four is when we
start to see a either secondary symptom
phase just because of a bimodal nature
of the inflammatory process but this may
also be when we see secondary bacterial
infections so really the way we guide
the secondary symptomatic phase is
diagnosis diagnosis guided Therapeutics
what is going on why are they starting
to feel bad here during week three four
and then once we've looked is it a
bacterial is it inflammatory is it
thrombotic then we want to base what
we're going to do based upon that
diagnosis
and then the tail phase the tail phase
is tough we we have millions of
individuals who had acute covet it
didn't just last five days it didn't
just last 14 days it didn't just last 30
days we have individuals now
60 90 even individuals two years out who
continue to suffer who've actually gone
on and developed the tail phase what we
refer to as long covet or post-acute
sequelae of covet
um
what are what are we looking at in these
individuals we say fatigue but it's not
just I'm tired this is debilitating
um fatigue this is the the inability to
to do their job uh these are triathletes
who have problems going up and down
stairs
um these are mothers who carry their
child for several minutes and now they
need to collapse this is really a
debilitating fatigue there's a
significant cognitive impairment that we
see in a lot of individuals this isn't
just
um you know oh I'm just not thinking
clearly this is I'm not thinking clearly
I can't do my job I can't function
College professors who can't even sign
their name on a check because they've
lost the ability
um pilots who can't go back and fly
planes a number of pulmonary issues
might be seen cardiac issues
GI issues insomnia mental health and the
list goes on one of the nice things I
will say at this point is we're at least
starting to get a sense that there are
different types there are different
buckets in the tail or long covid
patients and sometimes they can respond
to certain things so there is actually
some optimism here if it's new onset
migraines we can work with our
neurologists if it's cardiac issues
there actually are interventions that
can be helpful mental health really
difficult to access but really critical
for these individuals
and sort of bringing it all together
all right so hopefully people are are
realizing that timing matters you want
to get those vaccines active and passive
you want to do those behavioral
modifications before you're exposed
putting that n95 on after you've sucked
in a whole bunch of virus getting that
vaccine after you've already been
infected not quite what we we hope so
use those pre-exposure modalities and
then once you get into that first week
that's where we can make the biggest
difference let's go ahead and do that
let's not let some media conversations
scare us away from what the science is
showing us and then we want to really
watch our high risk people for that
second week that's when we start looking
at immune modulation anticoagulation and
unfortunately we have a lot of folks out
there with long covid but let's be
positive there's a lot of studies we're
learning more we're moving forward and
some of our symptom-based Therapeutics
are actually helping these individuals
so if you want more information we we
keep a website updated every week with
articles that are worth reading we also
do a weekly clinical update I try to
keep people up to date what's the latest
literature what have we learned because
this has changed it's changed over time
and if you're still treating the way you
did two years ago even the way you did a
year ago you're not giving your patients
um the level of care that we would like
to see them get so let's try to keep
them updated uh also welcome to shoot me
emails and uh hopefully now I will enjoy
some live q a
well Dr Griffin I want to thank you for
that informative presentation and we are
starting the live q a portion of this
webinar so I want to encourage our
audience to go ahead and submit some
questions now just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll get um those
questions that come in and you know as
we're waiting for these questions to
come in are there common questions Dr
Griffin that people have around this
particular presentation that we can
maybe zero in on as people are typing in
their questions
you know the big the big takeaway that I
hope people get is um one is the
vaccines are working the vaccines are
preventing um you know they're really
giving a disconnect between infection
and people dying
um you know if people with the short
memory January of 2021 right after
vaccines became available before we
really rolled them out we were looking
at over 3 000 deaths a day
and now we have more infections out
there but yet the deaths have dropped to
one-sixth of that and I think that's
because our vaccines are really keeping
people from ending up in the hospital
they're keeping people from dying of
covid
um but you're going to get infected and
I think that's and then the second
hopefully people are going to really
realize that we can do stuff now so when
that patient gets diagnosed just don't
tell them you're probably going to be
okay that might be true but for those
500 people that die a day if we had
jumped in we could really reduce that
number most the majority not all covet
deaths are preventable
yes absolutely and I I see that we have
a couple of audience members writing in
that they really appreciate your
presentation I don't see any um
questions coming in at this point but I
do want to say that any questions that
are not submitted today you can still
ask those questions because our speaker
will address those via con your contact
information you provided at the time of
our registration and Dr Griffin again I
want to thank you for your time today we
really appreciate it
um and oh actually there was one more
question that just popped up and I I
want to thank this audience remember
um this person says what about children
what about children in regards to
therapies and vaccines
it's a great question yeah so uh you
know as we know children are at lower
risk but they're not at no risk and
unfortunately we have had over a
thousand children die from covid right
and that's that's much more than we ever
see you know with a with flu things like
that
um you know and about a third of the
kids that ended up in the hospital and
there were thousands of kids in the
hospital were before this um you know
for all apparent you know completely
healthy kids so it is an issue for
children so we do have vaccines and we
encourage them I say across the board it
doesn't matter what age you are getting
a vaccine is always better than getting
coveted we worry about heart issues boy
a lot more heart issues with getting
coveted than getting the vaccine so
number one is the vaccines but some of
these Therapeutics particularly REM
death severe is available all the way
down to 28 days of age so you know you
want to you want to have that
conversation with the pediatrician I'm
not a huge fan of the government telling
us who should get vaccinated but talk to
your pediatrician have that conversation
decide what's right for you across the
board
children are better off getting
vaccinated than getting coveted and
there are therapies those therapies
again are not for everyone but if you
have a child who has risk issues then
there are therapies that can be employed
and again timing matters if you've got a
child who has risk factors that first
week that that's the time to jump in
thank you so much and it looks like we
actually do have some more questions I
love it uh thank you to our audience how
much is the ancestral monovolent booster
dose effective against ba4ba 5 ba 2.75
yeah so I think a big game changer was
was Omicron you know initially we had
two doses of the ancestral vaccine and
and we were doing pretty well
maintaining that 90 reduction in
progression to death but Omicron really
made this a three dose series but what
we just saw actually just over the last
week is the introduction of the bivalent
vaccines and so the really comparison
was what if you get a shot of that
original the ancestral versus the
bivalent the bivalents are going to give
you about twice the antibody levels that
you get with the ancestral but that was
really the difference that we saw
between Pfizer and moderna with the
original vaccine so we're optimistic
that the the new bivalents are going to
give us a little bit of a higher
antibody levels but we don't know yet
what that's going to translate into what
we're really after with our vaccines
which is reduction in hospitalization
reduction in death but what we did see
is with three shots of those and
ancestral that we actually were getting
broadening of our neutralizing we're
actually getting neutralizing antibodies
against ba5 and we actually saw
continued protection against death and
progression of hospitalization even with
the ba4 and 5 from those original
vaccines
thank you so much now there's a lot of
distrust toward the science community
and CDC specifically for example
anti-vaxxers what do you think could be
done to improve the trust toward the
general public I love this question
yeah no this is this is a great question
yeah and I think we need to go back to
the original Paradigm um and let's talk
about children again because that's okay
if you have a question about what's
right for your child
um I don't think you should go on to the
internet I don't think you should wait
for a press release you should talk to
your child's pediatrician your child's
family practice doctor your child's
provider have that conversation find out
about what's best for you there's a lot
of media out there and I understand
um but I think we should go back to that
part as someone you can trust I'm not
sure you can trust that that social
media influencer
um really if you don't trust your
pediatrician you got to get a new one
find that pediatrician find that family
doc you trust have those conversations
figure out what's right for you
great advice and we have time for one or
two more questions what if a virulent in
vaccines turns to virulent
yeah so the the nice thing actually
about our vaccines as opposed to we'll
say the Chinese vaccines
um I mean the current vaccine technology
um the MRNA vaccine technology there's
no virus in there so there's no ability
for those vaccines to actually give you
the disease it's the same true for Nova
backs some of our old approaches and
we're seeing a problem with this with
the oral polio which we're trying to
move away from is if you use a vaccine
which is really just a form of the virus
that is made less virulent there is
always that possibility that it can
revert back and that that child we saw
in Upstate New York getting that polio
paralysis because of a vaccine strain so
there is a big advantage to the modern
vaccine technology without that risk of
a virulin turning into virulence
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question
this audience member says I have a
friend in her 30s who will not get the
vaccine because she's terrified of her
immune system setting off her eczema and
psoriasis do you have any evidence-based
research in regards to this and I would
just add to this from my own personal
question because is there a site for
these kinds of issues where there are
specific health concerns about you know
whether or not you should get the the
vaccine is there a place where people
can go to see those things just to add
on to that question yeah no so this is a
great question and this is this is not
again
um you know something you want to be
Googling and who tells them what you
know if you've got eczema you probably
have a physician that works with you
that helps you with that and the great
thing to do is to have that conversation
let them know your fears your concerns
um in general your risk of having a
flare and getting into trouble with
covid is higher than the the risk with a
vaccine and we certainly are living at a
point where most of us are saying it's
just a question of when you've had covid
when you're going to have covet how many
times you're going to have covet and so
really you're trying to choose between
the lesser of two choices am I going to
go ahead and get covid without the
protection and see what impact that has
on the eczema or am I going to get a
vaccine under controlled circumstances
coordinate with my physician if I have
an eczema flare so yeah again I keep
sort of you know echoing the same
message we need to get back to if you've
got a medical question talk to your
trusted care provider be careful of what
you read out there on the internet on
social media as we've learned lately
people are willing to say things that
they know aren't true if it puts money
in their pocket so let's talk to people
that we can trust people who really are
committed to taking care of us and
giving us the best science-based advice
Dr Griffin I want to thank you for your
time today and your important research
and I want to thank our audience for
joining us today and remind you that
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until September 7 2024 and
Labyrinth will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone be safe bye-bye